so
plastics
plastics come in all shapes forms and
colors they are everywhere they're in
our makeup it packages our food and
insulates our homes they are in
airplanes and our favorite electronic
devices
they are truly a remarkable material
but so are its troubles
and we produce and consume plastics in
staggering quantities since it's been
mass produced the world has created over
10 billion metric tons of it
half of them just in the past 20 years
i have been investigating plastic
pollution about a decade
and i try to align my personal choices
as a consumer with the aspirations of my
research and you may think oh that's
easy you know how to do it
but actually it's not sometimes it's
impossible to avoid single-use plastics
the system is built that way
the dominant narrative about plastics
tell us that this is a consumers and a
waste management problem
who of us here have not heard about
details of gigantic plastic islands
floating in the middle of the ocean
which by the way
it's not true
and that low-income countries are to
blame for most of the plastic waste
entering in our oceans
but this narrative is a misleading
oversimplification
of a much bigger and much complex story
plastics and their chemical additives
are really a climate problem
now
we need to think of plastics from a
systemic perspective
so let me take you through the journey
of plastics
plastics contribute to climate change
from before the moment they are produced
so to long beyond the moment they are
disposed of landfill or drift into the
ocean
and it will remain in the environment
for centuries degrading ecological
processes
for 99 of all plastics the starting
point is fossil fuel hydrocarbons oil
gas and coal are extracted and refined
to produce plastic and other synthetic
chemicals
and those processes generate greenhouse
gases such as co2 and methane
studies indicate that if nothing is done
the production of single-use plastic
alone
will contribute to more than 10 percent
of all greenhouse gas emissions by 2050
and the thing is that our use of plastic
lasts often just a few minutes or a few
hours then we throw them away and that
generates further emissions
and we know that our recycling system
doesn't work
it's broken everywhere
and recycling system and recycling
plastics is hard and not cost
competitive
most of the waste that has not been
landfilled or incinerated domestically
is shipped across the planet
and it reaches low-income countries
where they are expected to be recycled
but
this is one of those hypocrisies of
globalization where rich countries
outsource their problems to low-income
countries and we know that these
countries do not have the capacity nor
the technology to deal with them in a
soundly manner
and so
huge amount of plastics are illegally
incinerated informally dumped or get
lost at sea
and as a result
millions of tons of plastic every year
gets into our environment
but even plastics that are soundly
managed emit greenhouse gases
once plastic enters the environment
landfill are dispersed in soil or water
they start a process of breaking down
into micro and nanoparticles i will just
call them microplastic for the sake of
the conversation today
and these processes of breaking down
emit powerful gases such as methane
ethylene and co2 and that's true for
both traditional and biodegradable
plastics
on the surface of microplastics a new
microbial commun new microbial
communities can grow we call them the
plastic sphere
and the biological activity also release
additional co2 and nitrous oxide into
the environment creating the possibility
of further magnifying the climate
problem
and is that microplastic can also impair
the growth and the photosynthesis
capacity of phytoplankton which are the
microorganisms producing much of the
oxygen we breathe
but also microplastics can have toxic
effect of soil plankton
and
the health of these organisms are
essential for the functioning of all
aquatic food webs
and unfortunately the problems run even
deeper
microplastics bind with the so-called
marine snow which are made out of the
clamps of bacteria plankton and other
organic material that sinks down into
the ocean depth acting like a biological
carbon pump
but microplastics risk affecting this
marine snow
and potentially decreasing the capacity
of the ocean to absorb and sequester
carbon from the atmosphere
and microplastics can be decreased in
the reflective property of snow and ice
potentially accelerating
the melting of glacier and polar ice so
we have early enough indications that
plastic pollution is starting to change
the processes that allow the earth
climate system to work
and this pollution is not a localized
phenomenon
microplastics are everywhere from the
mountain tops of everest to the deepest
sediment in the mariana trench
they are in the air we breathe
the water we drink
and the food we eat
they are now found in our bloodstream
and our lungs
and personally the most terrifying in
the placenta of our around unborn
children
now of course plastic is a great
material it's versatile and durable
and
in many ways it has allowed modern
civilization to develop in the way it
has
but
it also comes with a lot of problems and
the outlook is worrying
today the total mass of plastic is twice
the total mass of all living organisms
on the planet but still
fossil fuels companies seize hydrocarbon
as their primary growth sector
projecting a 30
increase of virgin plastic for
single-use plastic just
in the next five years
we already see an accelerating pace
in producing and releasing new chemicals
because there are many many kinds of
plastic each one the result of a
different chemical formula and we know
that this is incompatible with this with
a stain within the safe operating space
for humanity
and given how plastics impacts
the climate and the world's social
ecological system
this would spell a catastrophe
but wait i'm not saying that we are
completely doomed yet
there are solutions and is that
worldwide entrepreneurs and companies
are creating new designs and material
that can substitute traditional
single-use plastic
and social movements are consolidating
and educating people to reduce their
plastic footprint
and pressuring local and world policy
makers to enact strong policies
and scientists are collaborating more
than ever communicating the urgency to
limit not only the volume but the
chemical diversity of plastics
and early this year
representatives from over 170 nations at
the un environment assembly adopted an
initiative to end plastic pollution
committing all these countries to
participate in creating by 2024 a
legally binding agreement that addresses
the full life cycle of plastics from
production to design
to disposal
we need to stop thinking of plastic just
as a waste problem one that can be
solved by changing consumers habits
alone
and stopping using plastic bags we need
to think of plastics as a climate
problem
as a product that creates damage along
all its journey from the drilling up of
hydrocarbons to the spread of
microplastics and that can only be
addressed in a systemic way
thank you